hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna deploy our app so if this is the
first time watching just a little recap
we are on day 8 of a project we're
building a web app game it's just a very
simple math game to help children who
are new at math learn addition and
subtraction multiplication and division
so we build out basic functionality
really really basic UI and I'd like to
actually deploy this so that I can start
testing it with my kids and you all
could check it out and play it or give
advice on what which should be the next
set of updates without having to
actually actually pull down the code and
run it locally so that's the plan for
today we're gonna deploy before we start
I just want to give a shout out because
we had another pull request so siddhu's
I'm not sure I pronounced that it's s ID
oh you so let me know how to pronounce
that if you're watching or if someone
knows how to pronounce that cuz I'd love
to get it right we had a pull request
and it's a restart button so we didn't
have a button once you won the game you
had to manually refresh the page to go
back now we have a restart button button
which is a great idea so just want to go
through this really quickly just to
bring everybody up to speed on what's
changed
so in our app das file we now have this
handle restart function and that just
dispatches an action and here's the
actual button so just a normal reactive
button it even has the accessibility
label which is awesome and when you
press the button it just calls that
handle restart function
and then that triggers the action here
in our reducer are a producer Jas and
that's going to change our state at some
point restarts Hey
so we have our mode and our operator so
remember the mode is whether it's like
multiplication addition you know
whatever and then our operator is the
actual sign that will appear in the UI
all right so that's awesome I've already
merged this pull request so if you're
trying to follow along definitely do a
git pull update or if you fork to update
your fork because those those changes
are now in there and that's what what
we're gonna work with today and
hopefully what we're gonna push so I see
a lot of people are in chat what's up
everybody if you have any questions I'll
get to those after our first break so it
looks like there were some questions
some of them got addressed by other
members of the community here so I think
we're good right now somebody just asked
for a link to this repo it's in the
description to this video along with
some other links to some of the tools I
use some of my social media accounts my
youtube channel so there's I try to put
every link that you might want from the
stream in the description so check there
first if it's not there then you know by
all means ask you know I'll put a put
the link in the chat or put another link
in the description I'm gonna start my
timer so when this timer is going the 25
minutes timer I mainly just gonna be
focused on the code and I'm not gonna
glance over at the chat often once the
timer goes off I'm gonna go back to the
chat and I'm gonna try to get through as
many of the chat message as I can within
like five minutes and then we'll go back
to the code today we might not we'll see
I don't anticipate this work going
longer than one 25-minute period and the
rest can be for questions but you never
know
I could mess something up and it could
take a lot longer so that if you've seen
my
previous streams then you know the
messing stuff up is a frequent
occurrence on the streams let me check
I was just checking the stream health
quickly before I got started I don't
want to get into anything if y'all can't
actually see what's happening all right
so here here's our app right
I just want to verify like the things
are working before we deploy so let's
just go through around and hit that
restart button and then we can deploy
let's see oh you know what I still
haven't implemented the Enter key to be
able to work here and I keep forgetting
to do that so if somebody wants to make
an issue in the github repo about that
right now then that would be awesome
otherwise I'll try to remember to do it
this time all right we got that one
right I keep trying to hit answer I know
it doesn't work all right so now cool it
says victory and we have a restart
button we can restart yeah and it goes
back awesome now let's check out
deployment so I don't know if anyone
remembers when we first started this
project we did we use create react app
and it's like in our package JSON this
might look familiar if any this is like
the standard create react app package
JSON the only thing that we've added
really I think is react art and react
native web everything else is exactly as
it is normally and create react app so I
thought hey we probably could just
deploy this like any create react app
app so I've gone to the create react app
Docs and I've went to the deployment
section and I'm gonna scroll down and
get to the some of our different options
so you can see we can do a sure if
there's firebase but we're gonna try
github pages so I considered a few other
options for deployment but I think it up
pages would be nice because it'll keep
it all centrally located and github
right now
and this is a nice feature like to demo
because this costs nothing it's it's
pretty simple and it's linked up to your
your get commit so every time we push to
master it will update our github pages
so I think that's probably the simplest
way to go at this point all right so a
few changes we need to make we need to
add this homepage right to our
package.json so let's just copy and
paste an update a bit here so this we
can we can add this wherever we want I'm
gonna add it in right here
so we have a home page and this is I got
a replace with my username so Jessie I
go and then the name of the app which is
battle math I must say that I'm gonna
double check that I name the github repo
the same thing that's who
yep battle math occasionally I'll have
the project folder locally be named
something different than the the github
repo so always worth a double check ok
so that's step one done can you all see
this font is it too small let me know if
it's too small I'll make it bigger you
can also go here if you want I'll put
the link in the chat right now if you
want to check out these these Doc's
yourself so it's whenever you run NPM
around build you'll see a cheat sheet
with instructions on how to deploy to
github pages ok cool but let's add our
deploy scripts right
so we're getting we need to add gh-pages
first of all so the it's a package right
so let's go here to our terminal yarn
add gh-pages so we are using yarn
instead of regular NPM for this project
so I I prefer yarn but regular NPM is
will definitely work alright cool so now
you can see we have gh-pages as a
dependency and we need to add some
scripts so we're gonna add a free deploy
and deploy which this is gonna come out
weird cuz of that plus sign but we'll
deal with it when we get in there
okay I was just reading with this set
down here and this is only for github
user pages and not project pages so you
should be good with just this this is
the ploy scrip so let's add these I'm a
DS here at the bottom let's do that okay
so we have our pre deploy which dis runs
our build right and then we have our
deploy which will actually use gh-pages
and deploy I'm assuming build here would
be trying to find our build directory
right and final step deploy the site by
running npm run deploy or in this case
we can just run yarn deploy and since we
set up that pre deploy and everything I
believe this will save us from having to
manually do a build first alright so I
think the way it will work is if I hit
the floyd-- it'll run plea to pre deploy
automatically first let's verify that
make sure I save this yep and let's do
yarn deploy yep so it looks like it's
running the build first so now we can
see we have a build folder that's
appeared what it's doing here is it's
going to take all of our components and
everything and turn it into a a set of
JavaScript files right and so we could
looks like it's done so we can check it
out so you can see we have a bunch of
these like settings files we have an
index.html so this can run as a static
website basically like you could spin up
nginx
and just point it to your next out HTML
and it would work
so all of our actual files that we made
are now in our CSS and j/s and you can
see they've been so we have our map
files but we also have this which is
minified javascript and this is all the
stuff that we've that we've written but
it's all kind of condensed down right
and we could check out our CSS this is
minified you know CSS it's all in one
line right so that's all that actually
gets pushed when you create when you
when you use react it's just some
JavaScript and CSS files just like like
that so it's pretty cool now we have
another step on the github side of
things so we need to make sure that we
enable github pages the the branch so
we'll go into github which should
already be yep already in there so let's
go to the settings for this project so
these are the the particular project
settings not your your profile settings
and so I think it's on the main page
here yep github pages alright great so
it automatically did this which is
awesome that might be like the default
now for some reason I remember like
years ago you had to manually set it you
couldn't just default it to that but I
think maybe that changed or maybe I'm
crazy and I'm remembering wrong but it
seems to me like at one point this was
necessary to enable that and you could
point to different brands you can still
point to different branches it looks
like alright cool
[Music]
that should be it let's double check in
the docks here but I think that's it all
right we don't have to worry about
client-side routing at least not yet
because we have no routing going on all
right this is all just one page the URL
does not change at all if you did have
some routing going on it's a little bit
more difficult to use github pages but
not impossible
okay we have no problem so far so we're
not going to troubleshoot and that's it
and you can see there are other options
like if you wanted to deploy in Heroku
natla fie now now was probably what I
was gonna go with if we didn't do get up
pages I love now you could check out
like some of my earlier streams I use it
that's a great a great way to deploy
very simple s3 cloud front surge I have
you searched before I usually use surge
for my presentations like my conference
talks and stuff I always do my slides as
react repos and I deploy them like with
with search oh and you can publish to
NPM that's pretty cool I didn't realize
that was I guess it's not built-in
functionality so you have to use a tool
okay all right awesome now we should be
able to go here and see our site alright
awesome and you can see everything's
small again cuz I didn't increase the
size artificially but let's just test it
out make sure it works what's that 11:4
let's get one wrong cool
of
all right awesome and we should be able
to switch and get these crazy changes
all right cool
so now let me put that link in the there
in the the chat and I also want this
link to show up on our github repo so
let's go back in here and let's provide
here our website right we may as well
give a little description there we go so
now when anyone comes to our repo not
only can they see our code but they can
click right here to get the actual app
okay so that's cool and I mean of course
you could put any URL you want that
you're not limited to get our pages
let's see okay we still don't have still
I still haven't changed the the readme
and let's add that issue that I keep
talking about right here so add sorry
what a terrible mistake to make on the
keyboard or if anybody caught that looks
like there's Kizer right next to each
other and submit on enter answer key for
us okay
oh cool Wow
related issues that's interesting yeah
I'm gonna try that has anybody seen this
this is a new feature github will
automatically try to find related issues
so that you don't make like the same
issue again and our small repo not a big
deal but on bigger repos this is a big
deal of people duplicating issues
instead of looking through the backlog
of issues so yeah I'll definitely try
that that's cool I'm gonna submit that
great alright so now we have two issues
and see let's check our labels see if we
can I want to label both of these as
good first issues
so they're both pretty pretty basic and
[Music]
help-wanted whoops I didn't wanted to
actually label them as help 1 and label
Help Wanted there we go
okay so I like to keep the issues
labeled in the repose and that way
people who come can see what issues I
would actually want worked on if
anyone's interested in working on them
sometimes people will put in an issue
and it it may not be something that I
even want in the project but this way
everybody knows like yes I do want help
on this issue so it's it's up for grabs
and also they will these as these are
good first issues they're pretty easy
this one is involves no coding it's it's
just writing in English although if we
want to have readme in different
languages I'm cool with that too and
then this one is add submit on entry key
fresh so a little bit more code involved
but this is a pretty common thing that
we need done and react so not shouldn't
be a too difficult thing to add in
alright let's see sorry about the yawns
again
Oh so here's what I'm gonna do we've
gotten that done without running down
our timer so I'm gonna go to the chat
now and answer all the questions and
we're gonna see how much time we have
left at that point and determine whether
or not we want to code more or just save
it for for the next stream let's see I'm
scrolling all the way up to the top try
to get through all the chat at this
point so if you do have any questions
you can put them in the chat now I'll
take you know any questions fine as long
as it's not like inappropriate right
so he'll want suggestions for Python
courses you know what the Udacity
Udacity has some free courses along with
paid nanodegree programs but their intro
to computer science I believe is done in
Python so you would learn Python syntax
alongside of learning a lot of computer
science concepts so I recommend that
but we did have a question about like
can I watch this even if I have never
learned react native and yeah definitely
it got answered by other people in the
chat which is awesome thank you but just
for anybody else who maybe he's not
looking at the chat don't worry if you
don't know react the react native or
even JavaScript's or anything right ask
as many questions as you need to a lot
of this dream is just figuring out
problems and figuring out problems is
the same no matter what programming
language you're using and really in this
stream like we didn't even do any
JavaScript stuff we we edited a
package.json file right this was
deployment which in this case required
no coding changes
Edwin says sup how's it going thanks for
watching
rabbit work says what's up hey how's it
going Umberto's here how's it going
someone asked what's this website yeah
so if you didn't catch at the beginning
there it's a game it's a math game which
now we have we have it here a basic math
game for children it's built with react
native web which allows you to build in
react native but run it as a web app in
a browser we will do builds for Android
and iOS later on too so those are coming
and if we can think of something else to
build to I'm open to doing that too I
actually do want to try out there's a
way that you can do a Windows 10 app so
I want to try that as well so there'll
be more deployments to different
platforms coming up Doodle says I've
never watched before so well welcome
thanks for watching
there's some discussion about a Windows
forms app tutorial so my Moon says
anyone know the reactant asked taught in
that full stack tutorial
yeah isn't there one I thought there was
a video that on on the free code camp
channel here that came out like that
bond burped that says there was a full C
char project tutorial by I am Tim quarry
but this tutorial is for a Windows forms
app I don't know if you asking something
showing both react and asked on that
yeah
actually you can do a Windows forms like
app and use chromium embedded framework
so there's it's it's called Saif sharp C
e F sharp and you can basically point it
to a URL with your react app but run it
as a Windows forms app on Windows so
that's that's possible it would be like
similar to what you can do with electron
except you wouldn't actually have your
app like package right it would be
running elsewhere
there actually is a electron net that
lets you use dotnet I believe dotnet
core but I'm not on absentia but I'll
let you use dotnet and react or whatever
javascript you want bundle it like an
electron app and then run it run it on
Windows can you hack NASA for me no I
can't and even if I could hack NASA I
don't think I would do it because I
would get into a lot of trouble for that
we had a question about what is a react
native web app so since I just answered
that I'm gonna skip that question
hopefully so master ask that hopefully
you caught the the answer there Akeem
says this is first time watching welcome
Hakeem thank you so much for watching
rabbit work says are you going to make
this mobile-friendly like what was the
point for react native for just building
a web app okay so like I I think I just
mentioned this where we're gonna do
mobile apps as well and maybe desktop
apps so this is just stage one I think
in some of the like the earlier streams
like day one or day two I explained more
about like why why I'm doing it like
this so if you want a fuller explanation
then check that out there but yeah we're
the web is just the first step for this
project
umberto had tried to post a link to a
dotnet project tutorial and it got
blocked so I just showed that link so if
you're interested in that scroll up a
little bit and find Umberto's link it's
it's now visible
yeah no face says how's it going you
still need to improve the colors yeah
for sure
we need to improve the colors I know I
said I would maybe be able to look up
some color schemes but I didn't things
have been really busy at work and at
home
officially you don't know I have four
kids and they're all small so nine and
under so I obviously am busy with that
but also I'm in the process of buying a
new house for my family so we're trying
to pack up everything now and I'm
talking with like banks to get a loan
and a realtor and insurance people so
it's been busier than normal
I'm also trying to be healthy so I've
been going in a couple days a week you
wanting to work early and working out at
the gym there so I have less time than
normal so I'm trying to keep up with the
stream as best I can because I think
it's it's a really awesome thing and so
I'm gonna keep trying to make sure I
carve out some time for this dream but I
don't have a lot of time to work on this
project aside from my stream time
run says hello from Japan hey how's it
going what time is it right now in Japan
Davis does anyone know if these are
recorded here yes they are so you can
check it out all the videos of this
project are in their own playlist
I think it's react native web project
playlist or something like that and then
every livestream that I've ever done for
free code camp is in a giant playlist
called
live coding with Jesse and I also have
other live streams and tutorial videos
on my youtube channel the links in the
description
Moustafa says udemy has some great
Python courses ok so I haven't checked
out any Python courses on udemy or you
to me I don't know how you say that I've
heard both but I've I've seen some other
good courses on there for other
languages so that's probably a good
place to check Dave says thanks for this
Jesse is this a series and for bass
foundational idiots like me know nothing
about react well don't be so that'll be
hard on yourself
yeah this series I I want this it is a
series and I want this series to be as
beginner-friendly as possible we work on
stuff sometimes that's really beginner
friendly and sometimes we work on things
that are more advanced but I'm always
open for questions even if you have a
question that you think is just so basic
don't worry about it I'd love to answer
the question they're probably a lot of
other people that are have the same
question either live or that we'll watch
later so and it's good and it's a good
opportunity for me to make sure I
understand the basic stuff as I explain
it right and it helps me to realize what
I don't know you know if I get questions
I have no idea what they are then I know
where there are like holes in my
learning
so it's I love the questions and if
there's anything I can do to help for
beginners like speak up
I mean I want to make real projects so
it can't always be beginner level but I
still want to try to be helpful okay
Dave said there are also Python courses
in EDX and Coursera and free okay mi u P
all caps as he's coding hard I'll say
this it can be right there are parts of
coding that seem pretty easy and there
are parts that seem pretty hard it just
kind of depends on what you're working
on like and when I first started out a
lot of it seemed hard now that I've been
doing it for a while there's a lot of
stuff that's easy but now there's even
more stuff that I didn't even know about
that is hard right so that's I think
that's cool though right there it's
there's always a challenge in
programming so it's like anything if you
want to be good at it you have to
practice so I'm not gonna say it's
impossible it's because it's certainly
not it's doable for anybody but it just
takes work
let's see
[ __ ] Facundo says can you clean your
room it's disgusting you can't even see
it I have a bookshelf and some some
tablecloths hanging up anyway this is my
basement so this is not my room it's a
corner of my basement right now so I am
gonna get a real office when I move I'm
gonna have space to build an office so
this was just temporary let's see
no face says how about have math
questions moving down or across the
screen and you must answer each question
before they reach the edge of the screen
that would be a cool mode I don't want
that to be the base mode because that's
like an added level of stress for people
who are just learning but I think that
would be a cool like advanced mode we
also get people saying hello from just
all over the world so I'm kind of just
skipping those for time but I do see
them and hello I appreciate it
see
creative girl says hello is the freak up
camp curriculum the same as the free
kick up videos free code cam videos on
YouTube no so the the curriculum is is
different it it covers a lot of stuff so
basically like full sack web development
is covered in the curriculum it is I
guess we should just go there right now
so free code camp org has this this
curriculum so if you like time go
through a little bit let me try to find
one I wonder if it'll let me just go
into one there we go so like in in a lot
of the lessons it gives you a little
instruction here and then you have a
little spot where you can like type
stuff and it will show up here alright
so you have like a code editor and then
it live refreshes alright and then some
of the later lessons
you actually have was the project's
friend and libraries so you'll you'll
have these objectives user stories so
you build it on your own using your own
tools right but yeah they're not linked
to the videos the videos could be
helpful resources to learn how to do
that but they are separate separate
programs good question
the valeriy you I don't up your name
v-a-l-e are I you says first time
watching this thanks for watching and I
hope you liked it let me know if there's
anything anything I can do to make it
better let's see it says how long will
this video be we'll probably go for
another I think I'm almost to the bottom
something in like maybe another ten
minutes
Becky says p7 stands for part 7 project
7 alright yeah maybe I should explain
that so the videos all have this you
know have like today's is p7d 8 so
that's project 7 day 8 so this is the
seventh project that I've done on free
code camp live coding with Jesse series
and this is day 8 so it's another good
question so each project has its own
playlist but also if if you were just
looking at the big playlist of all the
projects you could easily see which
projects and which day of the project
were on
[Music]
Quadro says got four kids too bro I feel
you alright you know how it is I love
them I love I love kids I love my kids
but for kids is there's a lot of work
like it I wanted a towel I want to make
sure I'd spend time with each kid every
day so a lot of the time that I do have
where I don't have to work is taken up
by that so it's just like yesterday I
came home and my two-year-old wanted me
to read her a book and then my
nine-year-old has been doing some like
really basic computer programming and
building like Minecraft stuff and he
wanted to show me all the stuff that he
did so I went there then I went back out
and read my four-year-old a book and
then I grab something to eat really
quick so starving and then I went and
sat down and helped my seven-year-old
with her math homework and then at that
point it was time to get them all ready
for bed so I did all that so it's just
it's busy right like you just you know
if you're trying to be a good dad and
spent time with your kids like there's
not a lot of time left for anything else
but again like I love the kids like I
love being able to spend time with them
so not a complaint just just to sweat it
yo says hello what'd I miss
we deployed to github pages that's
pretty much what we did today so if you
want to see how that went
you can always check out the the replay
of this that'll be available a few
minutes after I in the stream but majid
says I'm studying unity3d I want help
please I don't know anything about that
so I can't help you but if anybody else
is watching and can offer some help you
know throw a comment here in the in the
chat plz mario says thumbs up for you
thank you I appreciate that
we have a question not sure how to
pronounce that so but the question is
hello can I pass my app and react js2
react native is this easy it depends on
how big your app is and how much you've
done you can't there's not an easy way
to convert react app to react native app
as far as I know if it was a small
enough react app maybe it would be
doable like I've done it but I've never
done it with a full-on fully developed
app right it's usually like at an early
point in the project I make a switch so
yeah it may be difficult to do it's not
impossible to do but it may be difficult
on mpg says in terms of performance is
there any bad side effect for running
Python no js' PHP or other as a service
in the same machine I don't really know
I mean the more stuff you run on a
machine like you're gonna have
performance effect but it just depends
like what are you running and how
powerful is that machine
the wrasse boy says it's an open source
yep yeah everything we do on the stream
is open source so feel free to use it
for whatever you want I don't think I
added a license yet you should do that
release making s let's make another
issue for that and MIT at MIT license
I'm gonna do issue all right not at
least I won't forget to do that
dave says wow you made my day I can't
believe this is free plus my monthly
donation to free code camp that's
awesome that you donate the free code
camp so thank you for that but yeah
everything free code camp does is is
free
hey Nicki's here says good morning or
noon what time is it we're at everybody
well where I am it's about a little
after 9:00 a.m. a user named Donald
Trump says can you it's this is a hidden
message so I guess I'll show it huh says
can you help me here my son wants to
learn it DM me on my gmail real Donald
Trump at gmail.com thank you well I I
bet I mean I need more details there and
what what exactly your son wants to
learn
this is nothing is in display that's
weird it make can everybody see what's
going on I think I only got one
complaint about it so let me know if
everybody can see it don don t says it's
2 p.m. in Germany that's cool
Jeremy I had the opportunity to go speak
at a conference in Germany at the end of
it so like in November maybe I think it
was November I was in Munich it was
awesome I really liked it too creative
girl says I have a problem about the
method of learning code what's the
effective way just following tutorials
learning on free code camp and knowing
the whole curriculum start to finish is
boring yeah I join the entire curriculum
from start to finish you know I I didn't
do that right so usually like you do
some stuff on the curriculum you do some
real projects you switch it up with some
videos some other tutorials like that's
the route that I went like I learned
what I had to learn to get projects done
because I was freelancing at the same
time as I was learning right so yeah I
would say switch switch up your modes of
learning whether it's tutorial like free
code camp tutorial or video or blog post
a book you know whatever if you get too
bored with one switch it up to the other
you know that's totally fine sometimes
you just need to work on a project you
know and just like try stuff see if it
works look at documentation right you
know do what you have to do to keep
things like fresh for you you know you
definitely aren't you don't have to
stick with just doing the curriculum all
the time you know hopefully that helps
answer your question a little bit let me
know if it doesn't now min says hola
amigo hola
let's see Mohammed says Savi I have to
go back to work is this going to be
available later yes it definitely will
be the recording will be available James
says it's 4:00 p.m. in Kenya Varun says
when will the next project start
whatever we get done with this one so
I'm not sure I just depends on how this
goes
you know if if it gets fun and we start
working on it and adding features maybe
it'll go for a little while
if it doesn't seem like there's a lot of
interest and we'll figure out another
project to start and to work on it's
it's 8 o 9 p.m. in Indonesia alright
that's a huge difference
is it difficult going from react to
react native so this is from Tom no I
don't it's not very difficult at all
there's just a few things that are
different once you kind of get past
those few things it's very very similar
like your life cycle methods are the
same the way state and props work is the
same right it's most of the core react
concepts are exactly the same nikki says
what are your thoughts on Google stadia
from a technical standpoint I think it's
awesome but I'm also scared for
everything it means like you own nothing
everything can be monitored etc actually
wow I never thought about that that's a
good point so yes so if you haven't seen
Google stadia look for it on YouTube I'm
sure there's a lot of videos about it
but it's like basically Google will live
stream games not just like watching
somebody else play but you can play the
game as a stream in your browser so you
don't need a powerful PC or the latest
console to play the best games you know
at high resolutions you just basically
need something capable of streaming
content so that could be a phone tablet
television
obviously a computer right I think
that's awesome I think it is really cool
that you don't have to put that big
investment into hardware to be able to
play but I didn't think about that idea
that yes like you won't own any games so
that does kind of sting
although anymore like you don't really
have physical so many things are digital
downloads now it's almost to that point
like I mean I know like technically you
own it and you've downloaded it but I
don't know for me mentally I'm like more
used to that part but the idea to that
everything is monitored I guess that's
weird
I mean I do take it for granted like any
game you play online can already be
monitored but now I suppose like even an
offline game would be monitored as well
so yeah I didn't think about that so I
don't know what I think about that
because I just I have to think more on
that probably my gut reaction is like
you know what like what I guess it
doesn't really matter if Google knows
like what video games I play but there
could be some issues that I'm just not
thinking about so yeah I guess there's
getting bad to it
let's see H s be ete I'm not yeah I
don't know that how to say that name but
anyway says you're doing the Lord's work
man with a like a fist emoji so thank
you I appreciate that
run says it's 10 12 p.m. in Japan I am
sleepy but I'm going to watch this video
all right that that might be the biggest
time difference right ten twelve PM
thoughts yeah that's that's pretty crazy
dave says how many coffees have you had
pre 9:00 a.m. to be pumped enough to do
this or you an early bird it's 12 13
a.m. in Australia wow wow that's okay so
actually I haven't had any coffee
so like for for Catholic people right
now it's it
Lent and during that time of the year
like we we give up something we it's
been like a sacrifice rate that we give
up so I decided that I'm only gonna
drink water throughout the time period
of Lent
so I actually haven't had any coffee I
haven't had any coffee for weeks now and
I love coffee and my wife makes espresso
every morning and I smell it and it's I
always smell it at work but it's a
little sacrifice really like it's not
compared to what a lot of other people
do on a daily basis like it's not a big
deal but it is hard in the mornings
right like trying to get pumped in the
morning is difficult normally I would
have definitely had like at least a
couple shots of espresso Dave says what
did you do Jesse to get where you are
from square one and you have a different
career like do you have a blog etc so I
do have a YouTube channel and I do have
some videos on that channel kind of
explaining like how I got here so check
those out I think I have a whole video
on like my path to becoming a developer
so you get a better explanation there
but like the short explanation is like I
started freelancing I have a business
degree originally I had a couple of just
kind of like jobs just to pay the bills
right a manager at a fast food place a
waiter I was a high school teacher for a
little bit and then I decided like I
hooked up with a friend of mine who had
a media marketing business and needed
someone to do some like freelance
contracting work so that's how I got
into the coding stuff and started
getting my own clients and then
eventually got a full-time job as a
front-end developer and now I'm a
software engineer so that's like the
very short version of my story like I
said you can get a longer version on my
You Tube channel
makes in the description to my channel
Szell Szell alum says how about Java I
haven't done anything with Java so sorry
about that I'm not the person to ask
about any Java stuff Don she says how
can I get started to contribute to open
source when do I know I'm ready you're
ready when you get a pull request merge
right like that's it you know don't try
the worst that can happen if you submit
a pull request is it doesn't get merged
right so just if you see a project and
you think like hey I think I can do this
I think I can fix this issue just give
it a shot try it right like so you don't
get it merged like maybe somebody will
be mean to you right hopefully it
wouldn't happen but it's possible but
that's bait that is the worst thing that
could happen really and that's not that
bad so just give it a try maybe they'll
come back and say actually could you fix
this or that right and then they that's
awesome because now you're you're
getting like some mentoring happening
right but give it a shot maybe you'll
get accepted and then once you get that
first pull request accepted and merge
like you've contributed to open-source
you're an open-source contributor so
it's it's definitely a scary thing to
get started it was for me for sure but
it's the only way to know when you're
ready is is to actually do it you know
give it a try
wired wrote says it's 9/16 p.m. and the
Philippines see do you have any advice
for freelancing I'm not sure where to
start but I really want that real world
experience I'd say the best thing to do
would be talk to people in your local
area even like talk to family just let
people know that you're interested
you're interested in doing some work if
you really really can't find any work
anywhere you could always pick a company
that has a terrible website redo their
website without even asking them like
just do a prototype and then show it to
them and say like hey this is what I did
or would you be interested in anything
like that at the very worst they say no
and you've gotten some good practice
right you could try some of those
freelancing websites
I have didn't ever really had that much
luck with the freelancing websites but
you know some people some people do so
that's another option but really like
just trying to make those connections
among friends family people in your
community that will spread and then that
like will tell other people like hey I
know this person that can do this work
and that's how you really start to get
more freelance business I stay Julian
says do you know how to connect my
sequel to JSON I I mean I don't know
what the official way to do it but I
mean basically like if you had an API
that would accept JSON and then save it
to a my sequel database like that's
that's the way to do that you could
pretty much do that in whatever language
you're comfortable with so I I don't I
mean like step by step I don't know like
off the top of my head how I would code
that but that would be that would be my
approach if I had to do that I would say
like alright let's set up my sequel
backlund and connect it to an API that
accepts JSON and then puts the data into
the database right
robust misconception says jokes aside
how long will it be until web
development is fully automated actually
will it ever be I don't know if it will
ever be but who knows right like trying
to predict what will happen in the
future is I mean just you're just
guessing right yeah so I don't think
it's gonna be fully automatic made it
anytime soon
but will it ever be I don't maybe also I
skipped one robust misconception says
it's 1420 and north Macedonia is is
reacts a bit hard to learn for the first
time I know JavaScript but I'm not an
expert
I don't think react is actually that
hard to learn it's it's not like you
pick it up
immediately right it takes a little bit
of work but I don't think it's it's too
difficult so like don't be afraid to
learn react it's it's pretty the
concepts are pretty straightforward it's
just a matter of like shifting the way
you think about how to interact with the
Dom and once you understand like that
you only ever change state and never
change the Dom directly then I think it
starts to like make sense and it's it's
easier it's a reason about so but I'd
say like you know only one way to find
out how hard it is and that's that's to
try it
Oh Nicky says in response to the
question we had about contributing to
open source Nicky says a good way to
start is to contribute to documentation
it's often overlooked and almost always
appreciated especially in a friendly
environment like the free code camp tour
guide that is great advice for sure
Mohamed says just joined what are you
doing we're just doing some question and
answer right now
earlier in the stream we did deploy our
web app to github pages so if you're
interested in checking that out you can
watch the recording later on I stayed
Julien says is it possible to make a web
in three days to make a website in three
days yeah for sure it's possible a
simple website is is pretty easy to make
it just depends on what you need it to
do
Dave says on scrim ba' tutorial I saw
react but I'm not sure the benefit since
it looks like JavaScript and HTML while
I learn another framework not joking
just confused a little all right yeah
that's a legitimate question so reacts
definitely has some benefits right it's
it's C it's definitely a very different
way of making websites than just
straight JavaScript and HTML for sure
like technically speaking there are
definitely some performance improvements
and things because of the way it
actually handles rendering things in the
Dom it's also allows for server-side
rendering like really easy so if you're
trying to make a progressive web app or
a single page application it's a lot
easier to make that search engine
friendly with react then it would be
like let's say if you made your own like
JavaScript web app or even using
something like jQuery or something right
so there there are definitely benefits
so
I guess I'm trying to think of a
resource that would list them I don't
know about a resource right now and but
that is a good question like why another
framework right but yeah I would there's
in general like I would say yeah like
why why I learn another framework that's
usually my mentality too
but I do believe that react fills a it
has a purpose and it makes making web
apps a whole lot easier
like ID from from coming from making web
apps with just regular JavaScript or a
bit of jQuery in HTML to then making web
apps with reacts it's so much easier
with react right things that were the
source of a lot of frustration and bugs
now like I don't even have to think
about it just works right really really
simple Abraham says hey I just did my
first pull request on this project
should I comment or something else to
point to related issue Oh awesome
yeah you can you can add it to an issue
if you just comment with like the number
of the issue I think it'll automatically
tag it yeah I think it will but anyway
that's awesome thank you so much so um
I'll get that pulled in soon or maybe
I'll pull it in like live on the next
stream but I definitely appreciate that
ffs in ethane cozy a thing cosy sorry if
I mispronounced and says getting advice
on getting an internship as a front-end
developer if I have HTML CSS JavaScript
basics and es6 see some them and some
Python
I would like apply so first of all I
keep applying for internships but also
try to like network and get so if
there's any conferences you can go to or
eat ups or events try to go to those try
to talk to people that may be looking
for interns right like let people know
be active on social media like
especially Twitter and let people know
that you want an internship so that's it
I mean sometimes it takes a while and
you got a you got to do a lot of you
know trying to connect with people but
that's that's definitely the way to go
nice nice layer says sorry about the
pronunciation says what do you think is
the best marketing strategies to sell
our web mobile app development service I
don't I guess it depends like on what
market you're targeting if it's just
maybe like small business markets then
you know you could like locally go to
like business groups like a lot of times
cities have a Chamber of Commerce that a
lot of business leaders are in sometimes
you can convince the Chamber of Commerce
commerce to let you speak at one of
their meetings and demo what you're
doing
you could just cold call a lot of
businesses you know just call them up
say here's my product can I get a you
can I do a demo can I do something right
like that's hard work it takes a lot but
that that also is a possibility you
could think about doing targeted
advertising right so those would be off
the top of my head those are my my ideas
but you know I haven't I haven't been in
the freelance business for a while so I
guess I'm a little bit rusty on like
marketing myself and my services so I
would definitely get another opinion to
run says which is easier Python or
JavaScript I don't I don't really know
I mean Python syntax is kind of cool
because you don't really have a lot of
special characters but I don't know if
that necessarily makes it easier
let me I'm gonna log in real quick to my
email for where to make sure I'm not
missing anything important
I'm almost done
with the live chat here
let's see Daniel says amazing where
Jessie I am almost done with a full
stack tract of free code camp what
advice can you give to a Nigerian
looking for work in the u.s. I guess
like just keep working on projects
definitely like work on your your
written and spoken English for sure your
written English right because people
won't if they're looking at a resume or
something and they see that the English
is not exactly right like that might
have a negative impact I mean it's you
know so just make sure like in terms of
like the American style right of of
writing write try to like match that
that's because I do like I see resumes
from people from other countries and a
lot of times they're way different than
what people in the US expect so like
make sure that you look at like us type
of resumes online and try to match that
right because that can be a big turn-off
to employers if they see something
really different and they think like you
know doesn't this person know you're not
supposed to do that or right so like I
always say that would definitely be
helpful like as a non-coding thing but
in terms of coding like always be
working on projects make sure you put it
out on github open source if you can so
that people in the US can see how good
your your quality of work is and then
you know just keep applying to like
everything that you can think of don't
be afraid to apply to stuff that you
don't feel like you're qualified for you
never know you could definitely get you
know someone could give you a shot so
just keep keep after it
karth karthik he says can I add MIT
license on your projects yeah for sure
that would be awesome
thank you I think o-z says does
experience always count I am second year
student doing software
dev I have more knowledge of languages
than personal projects experience yeah
well I mean you got to think of it this
way right like it's hard for a company
to know your knowledge of languages it's
much easier to be able to see someone
this github portfolio or see the
projects they did right so it's all
about what can you prove to an employer
so you need to have something to show
your knowledge right so that's why the
the actual projects and things are
important so yes like you may get coding
interviews and stuff but being able to
even get to the point of having an
interview somebody's gonna look at your
resume and they're gonna want to see
your projects and stuff before they even
think about actually talking to you so
try to make sure you do have projects
like I know for me if I'm looking at
resumes and I see somebody doesn't even
have a github or github account at all
like they don't even show it to me like
I'm way less likely to recommend that
that person actually be interviewed
because I then have no idea if they
really know what they're talking about
right so that would be my advice is you
know at least from my perspective that's
what I look at it's like I want to see
the code because the code is to me is
the proof that you actually know what
what to do all right cool okay so I've
gotten through all the questions so I'm
gonna finish up now and I get to work on
some more react native for my my normal
job and I'm gonna try to be back maybe
Friday with another stream I might have
to go into work Friday so I may not be
able to do a stream but anyway keep
looking out on your notifications for
free code camp I also put out messages
on LinkedIn Facebook Twitter and
Instagram on what I'm gonna do a stream
so if you like any of those social media
you know give me a follow on there to be
able to see the the messages about when
doing videos and stuff you follow my
youtube channel I do some streams and
videos on there sometimes - yeah and if
you like free code camp you know
subscribe consider donating we don't
charge for anything almost everyone that
works at free code camp does not get
paid it's volunteer so anyway and if you
think you'd like to contribute to free
code camp in some other way other than
donation then you know let us know you
know get a hold of Quincy or Bo Karns if
you want to do YouTube stuff so anyway
have a great day thanks so much for
watching and especially thank you to
everyone who's submitting pool requests
is much appreciated and very helpful so
yeah I'll see you next time bye